had there been cases of information
remains blood samples where it's not a
human origin and it's not of an animal
origin I don't know and we don't know
what it is I don't know I wish I knew
though because I've done a lot of
studies on Bigfoot and cryptids which
are which are Loch Ness monster
chupacabras things that people
scientists haven't seen yet so it's
considered not real but other people
will will swear no know why it exists I
would love to find some samples of that
a bones even I mean it because I I can
look at bones and tell you a lot about
them and say okay this is this type of
maybe it's a marsupial or Musil adore
stuff but no I I personally haven't run
across anything that's unexplainable yet
but I'm a scientist I'm not a skeptical
in scientist I'm a hopeful scientist
what about light orbs you know they say
decedent sometimes remains at a property
oh yeah in a light orb and then this is
the decedent's essence spirit you know
for if we're all energy and matter and
we don't really actually cease there's
parts of us remain so how do you explain
these light orbs or maybe that's not
part of what you do but if you were to
write it into something remains that
don't things that are still in the
atmosphere that you can't explain
whether they're human animal but they're
of some nature there's there's of some
substance there I don't probably not
explaining no no it's the subject that I
love actually I love paranormal and
things like that and I always say I'm a
scientist so take this with a grain of
salt if something cold less is out of
nowhere it goes but a little bit and
then Kurt and then disappears it still
came from somewhere it still did
something I will not say that orbs don't
exist because I've seen them in film I'm
not saying that they weren't made up but
why not
why not I've seen many many many many
many dead bodies I've only seen a
handful people pass away mostly family
members I've never experienced that
myself but I had experiences as a child
that had to do with lights and colors
and things like that that I can't
explain I do have a funny one though I
finally figured it out though I sleep
canna tonically sometimes I dream and I
incorporate what I see in my dream so i
think i'm watching ghosts walking around
the room and then when i wake up i find
out that i had been asleep with my eyes
open i just found that out a few years
ago my wife had had caught me so there
are scientific explanations for
everything as far as i am concerned if
there is no scientific explanation we
just don't know what the scientific
explanation is yet so in a script how
would someone determine that it's a big
question mark or is that in science
that's there there always has to be some
follow-up or law enforcement there has
to be some result from an action
maybe I can answer it this way there's
no such thing as a truth there's only
such thing as a fact and the fact is
only a fact until we've unproven it and
find something else that's I forget
there's a name I'm sure for it out after
somebody from Galileo's time or
something but if you it's it we revolve
around the Sun we'd all say we know that
now but there was years ago where they
thought that there was sudden revolved
around us things changed then they found
a new fact we may find another fact that
turns out we revolve around something in
the Milky Way and you know the Sun is
just a secondary or tertiary thing we're
getting very off the topic in deep here
but I like this kind of stuff just just
wondering yeah I'm of an ass to that in
terms of findings that that you could
not determine what species what whether
it was human animal it was the line was
to blur I can tell human versus animal
that part's can okay that part's easy
animals though being as Oh
archaeologists as well because I
consider myself a though archaeologists
animals are a little harder to to peg
but you if you've got a good field guide
it's much easier to narrow it down to
this is a moose or I mean you can go by
size too I mean I know what what body
parts they look like what the the
phalanges look like which is the the
finger bones or the carpals or the
tarsals which are the leg bones and
stuff like that and they look completely
different in different animals and
that's how we identify them it's the
pattern that we look at so we can still
identify things
you